[Music]
for the community for the LGBTQ
community and for those of us who were
inspired by the way the community
operated during the the height of the
AIDS pandemic there was a world that we
were living in where people were dying
in droves and we were at several
funerals a week and we were looking at a
government that has talked about how
compassionate they are and there was no
compassion coming to this community and
so there were pieces that were being
written places in which you were
beginning to see that people were
looking at this community in a new way I
mean you look at Elizabeth Taylor and
how she dealt with Rock Hudson and and
how she would go to Congress and talk to
them about getting money and funding and
and there was larry kramer and my friend
paul Minette who wrote the book borrowed
time and AIDS memoir and becoming a man
half a life story and you're watching a
community become a force a kind of
banding together to operate at a level
of community and commitment to each
other when there was no help forthcoming
from anywhere else you saw Cleve Jones
create the the AIDS quilt the the you
know the name is project the AIDS
Memorial Quilt you
you saw the normal heart Larry Kramer's
the normal heart and then you saw it
brought back to Broadway years later and
then Ryan Murphy turned it into the HBO
movie you saw Ellen DeGeneres talked
about being gay and coming out on
television Will and Grace Ellen on the
cover of
and what what happened was the community
began to take itself as a profound
powerful non victim assertive in the
world you saw Larry Kramer and you saw
act up get created you watched people
take care of their own
you saw families torn apart and parents
not coming to the deathbed of their sons
because they when they found out that
they had AIDS that meant that they were
gay and they cut them off so we were
living in a world in which a community
was turned upside down and became this
magnificent example to the world of how
to be of service
and I said to myself I want to be there
to be a support in any way that I can
and watching that and seeing that and
knowing that I wanted to be part of a
community that so inspired me with the
way that they were operating and you
began to see all of these stories come
up in our business you know on Broadway
plays and television and films and and
and movies I mean Tom Hanks winning the
Oscar for Philadelphia
you were watching something happen where
you I began to see that we were by the
example of the LGBTQ community we were
one human family we were all of us in
this and everybody said if one of us has
AIDS
everybody has AIDS and everyone took
that Syria
and then you began to see organizations
popping up all over the place I mean in
Los Angeles we were cooking for people
and delivering meals and that was
Project Angel Food and then here you had
God's love we deliver and you watched
people rallied to each other and care
from a depth of compassion that had not
been seen before and so those are the
examples that I would say really started
to move from a community out into the
world and I don't think we're far enough
yet I think we have farther to go I the
fact that we have same-sex marriages
just wonderful and due to the absolute
diligent work of so many people in the
community the the demonstration to me
about how we remove bigotry and
Prejudice and divisive nough sand
cruelty from the system all of our
systems around the world
this is the demonstration of where it is
happening and we're not there yet and
that's why for me being not why but the
the fact that I am on a show like
transparent that you can see on Amazon
Prime and some people know it and some
people don't know it and people laugh at
me when I say it's just I'm on the show
and they go yeah yeah we know but when
do you see that the time has come it is
an idea whose time has come like Victor
Hugo said all of a sudden we're in this
new zeitgeist of something that's
happening and jeffrey tambor described
it he said the the when week when
transparent came on he said the bow or
the the the arrow had already been shot
from the bow we were riding on the bow
it had already happened in the zeitgeist
and when you have somebody like Jill
Soloway whose parent comes out
at 70 years old and says actually this
is who I really am and what does it mean
to tell your family member the person
you thought I was that's not who I am I
will be brave enough courageous enough
out in the world enough longing to not
be on my deathbed and think what if I
don't do this will I regret it I want to
live the life I want to live I want to
live free and I want to live true to
myself I want to be authentic that to me
is the most remarkable courage in the
community because they are saying oh I
am this person this is who I am and will
you still love me if I tell you who I
really am and isn't that what we all
want that we want to be loved for who
all of who we are and so I think more
work needs to be done we're still doing
it
to the degree that we can somebody in
our community Michael Friedman that
genius who wrote Bloody Bloody Andrew
Jackson just passed away from AIDS
complications a few days ago we're we're
we're still in it and we are we are
called to come from the better angels of
our nature
[Music]